New service Teru nante, my sister knows about the double-stacked stage
Well, I've been rotten with flages since a while ago,
me,
berries
Come
again.
Ah ah
ah ah ah ah ah ah
ah ah I would have been scratched.
Ever since I saw you in the Crown Game, there's been something I've always wanted to confirm
That's why I gave up on the game
Partly because someone persuaded
me Why did you choose the windy path?
[Music] I
picked up some beautiful jewels.
Because I married
[music]
Chicken pie master koku I
've been brought down I'm called [Applause] Here comes the game
Come on kill everything that hits hard
Complete revenge It's
you first
Silver dara j